this is how the French police tried to
regain control by surging their numbers
here in Monte they faced another night
of running battles Now using armored
vehicles and specialized SWAT teams to
enter these volatile Estates
you could see there were more police but
it did nothing to stem the tension and
the anger
blue lights mixed with the orange glow
of flames the roads here are full of
scorch marks and peppered with burnt out
cars just a few minutes ago we
and we were threatened by kind of use
with with rocks and telling us to clear
out and look how quickly this can change
now this place has been flooded with
dozens of Riot police big armored
vehicle over there and above us a police
helicopter monitoring what's going on
all this disorder was sparked by the
death of a 17 year old called nayel
killed by a police officer who's now
been charged with voluntary homicide his
lawyer says the officer is truly sorry
that he didn't mean to kill the boy but
insists he did have to take action
Montez violence was not isolated the
disorder is spreading
another of paris's suburbs a supermarket
was looted and then satellite
[Applause]
there's more looting in this Central
Paris shopping district
the interior Minister Jihad dominar had
sent 40 000 police onto France's streets
he arrived at Police Headquarters and
announced at one in the morning to watch
events unfold
what he saw was a tableau of trouble
this was Marseille but fires were
burning all over France curfews were
brought in and ignored in a couple of
places and there were even reports of
CopyCat attacks in neighboring Belgium
the huge surge in police numbers was
supposed to bring a sense of order and
calm there's very little evidence that
it's worked Adam Parson Sky News nantair